[Music]
it's quite natural and understandable
that in this age of the internet
particularly for younger users who are
used to just typing in a few words into
Google and then getting all sorts of
interesting results that you would come
to somebody who you think has the
answers and you know put a comment to
try to try to get those but if you're
doing that you're probably circumventing
the very process that ideally I don't
know if your professor is any good or
not or if the test that you're studying
for is really about that but ideally you
should be acquiring that knowledge
yourself and there's something to be
said for going through the work to
develop that knowledge in your own head
rather than simply you know say reading
Wikipedia articles or asking people very
quick questions that they might answer
or might not so you don't want to
deprive yourself of that it's very
important especially when you are a
student and have the luxury of taking
classes with people that you make use of
what's available to you and that you
develop these these research skills
because they're not just going to be
useful for academic research they're
going to be useful for the rest of your
life
it's common enough for students to feel
a bit overwhelmed particularly when
they're approaching philosophy
especially if it's for the first time
when they're given difficult questions
to answer
from an instructor or when they're
prepping for some sort of test whether
that's in a class or a levels in Britain
or the IAS in India any of those sorts
of things it's it's it's natural to feel
a little overwhelmed because
philosophical concepts are difficult but
they're not beyond any average student
you can in fact develop a grasp of them
that's sufficient for the people who
want these answers to come back from you
and
more that you understand it the better
your answer is going to be so it's
important that you take a step back and
you say I think I can actually handle
this and if I can't I need to do
something a bit more substantive than
just throwing questions out there onto
the internet and hoping that somebody
will come along and provide me with an
answer because you know quite frankly
how do you know that the answers that
you're getting are actually on track if
you don't know enough about the topic
another thing to keep in mind is that
when it comes to those who are providing
answers like myself and it's
understandable that you would post
questions on my videos because I do in
fact talk about a lot of different
topics in philosophy those of us who are
working at a fairly high level and have
a lot of background and expertise to
draw upon are usually pretty busy so you
know if if I were to try to answer every
single question that gets put to me I
would require more than the 24 hours
that I have in a day so I frequently
don't address things that look like
people just looking for homework answers
or test prep answers if you're looking
for a substantive engagement on my part
in answering your questions of these
these types then you probably want to
consider booking me for a tutorial
session like what my other clients do my
time is in short supply and is valuable
and the expertise that I have to bring
can be very helpful for you not only in
dealing with whatever individual
question you have but in understanding
where it fits into the the wider realm
of philosophy but you know I I can only
do so much of that I already do answer
questions in my AMAs other online events
you know I do in fact address quite a
few questions and queries on social
media and YouTube so if what you want is
is somebody to walk you through the
stuff and help you understand it
consider the tutorial sessions otherwise
you know good luck with what you're
doing and I think you know just keep
plowing away at it and you will find the
answers that work for you and you want
to keep them up here in your own mind so
that you're developing as a person
through the assignments or the test
questions that are being assigned to you
[Music]